last summer we did shows down at
comic-con yes and I actually hosted a
panel at comic-con right you know and
you came out for the panel giant
audience mm-hmm and at one point you
said I don't have any water and you
would I think you were just asking has
anyone have any water and I offered you
mine you write a look of horror when I
offered you my water that cut me to the
core Charlie what the hell was going on
there would you think I'm some kind of
slobbering monster what's going on I try
to keep it clean
it wasn't an unopened bottle of water I
think that's an important point
right it was there was you thought I
might have been putting something in
there oh I just thought maybe you drink
out of it uh-huh I've got a little bit
of germophobia you're a germaphobe I try
to keep it clean okay okay you know
don't have herpes don't want herpes not
saying that you have herpes right my
quest my question is how did you know
Andy listen everyone calls you a cold
sores Oh Brian that's been going on for
years man you're good
no I do not have herpes good we could
have a little makeout late to that oh
good yeah let's have that be the lead
line for tonight's show it's Conan
without herpes is this been a prop like
okay in your line of work
good looking meeting man like you you've
got to do a lot of kissing scenes I know
and you do how do you handle that you
would think that would be the best part
of the job right ya know I wake up in
cold sweats that say listen I just I
don't want to kiss anyone but my
girlfriend's I don't know where this
start is in my life but well actually I
do but it's a long story but yeah over
the years I have feel like I'm your
therapist I know I do too
and I feel it was the idea of man very
awkward stop no no this is good for us
don't know where it's gonna lead okay
this is everything you've said is
perfect I think we should explore where
this begins because clearly you don't
want to talk about it and that's my cue
to say where does this come from in your
childhood well all I'm gonna tell you is
that if I ever write a biography it will
be called blood dog [ __ ] and the pursuit
of happiness
well now I'm more confused than ever
believe me I am too so welcome to my
life
so you're just you've always been afraid
of germs is that it yeah yeah what
happened was something happened in your
childhood
there was a parasite in dog poo in the
area of England that I grew up that as
improbable as this is if ingested would
turn you blind right and so there was a
lot of talk around this in my your eyes
twitching I understand because how do
you think I felt isn't they that's a
real easy way around that one Rockets
dog shits real good you might want to go
easy on it there's a rare sight sure at
the same time HIV yeah I'm also getting
some Jack Orioles about dr. cool that's
more things colliding and it give you a
little bit movie about your phobia
you